tom have you ever fallen asleep during a
movie
in theaters uh movies
at the movies almost definitely yeah
yeah uh you know what the second alice
in wonderland movie uh with johnny depp
fell asleep during the first act and i
woke up and wonderland had turned into a
scab
[Music]
nina what are the worst films
that hollywood's best actors have been
in i think you i feel like you you have
an answer to this question i do so
please tell me what it is i do it's
locked and loaded so
imagine that it is
late 2019 and you're going to the movies
and you're seeing a movie that stars
tony award winner anne mcallen tony
award winner james corden academy award
winner judy dench academy award winner
jennifer hudson emmy nominee idris elba
and rebel wilson is also
in this film
[Laughter]
imagine all of that and more jason
derulo's there for some reason i can't i
can't picture a movie like well what
what movie could you possibly talk a
movie like this must be amazing like
that wouldn't this cast has got legs and
it sounds like it always lands on them
this sounds so good
what's this movie it's nine lives
because it's cats i'm picking up oh okay
yeah no i was gonna say i was starting
to get a picture for what you were
talking about yeah you mentioned esp yes
it is yes tell us about the movie cats
oh where to begin um
i saw this movie as a joke and then it
was the last movie i saw in theaters for
two years and um that's the fact about
me that everybody should know i went as
a bit
and the joke was on me so cats is a bit
[Music]
let's say that i was somebody who wasn't
familiar with the plot of cat
yeah could you explain it to me no i
can't because there is no plot of cats
based on the musical by andrew lloyd
webber uh my nemesis because he wrote it
that's really the only reason why uh tom
hooper directed this movie and tom
hooper has a history of big budget
hollywood musicals because he also
poorly adapted les miserables in i
believe 2012. i am not a fan of that
adaptation i think it's
bad um it's it made you feel miserable
i'm gonna move on from that um
cats is a very weird musical to adapt
into a movie because it's basically cats
introducing themselves for 90 minutes
and then one of them gets to die that's
the end is that one of them is given the
privilege of
the sweet release of death and
so yeah you might be thinking why was
that even a musical and it's partly
because it was like
you know this disjointed fun thing that
people from out of town could go see and
the cat's cats would come into the
audience which sounds very upsetting to
me personally but people really liked it
because that musical made
so much money like an un
incomprehensible amount of money so i'm
sure that you know everybody was like
cats
it'll be a great success we'll get tom
hooper to do it we'll get this all-star
cast we'll get taylor swift to write a
new song it'll be great spoiler alert it
was not great the movie is a horrifying
trip into the uncanny valley like for
fans of polar express i guess i don't
know who this movie is for
and it is there's a there's a part where
rebel wilson unzips her own she unzips
her own skin and she eats cockroaches
with human faces on them at the end of
the movie dame judy dench looks directly
at the camera
and says cats are not dogs
that's part of movies
yeah but it has no context and you're
kind of just like okay um i spent a lot
of my theatrical experience of this
movie saying the word what
really loudly because there was
basically nobody else in the theater and
i didn't care
it is i mean everybody knows it's a bad
movie right like the the studio bullied
the special effects team into getting it
done faster so you have weird stuff like
i saw the cut with judy dench's human
hand wearing a wedding ring at the end
that was
like it's very jarring um
the cats don't have any size consistency
sometimes they're the size of a large
london statue and sometimes they're
smaller than a fork um
i could spend an hour to five days
talking about why cats is a bad movie
it's a bad movie and i still can't
understand how they called ian mckellen
and judy dench those two in particular
and were like because at least jennifer
hudson got the show stopper she got to
sing memory which is the song that
everyone knows from cats and it's the
only part of the movie that justifies
the existence of the movie even a tiny
little bit because it's a good vocal
performance but i just can't like the
call to judy dench's agent being like we
want her to play old deuteronomy and
look in the camera and say cats are not
dogs and somebody was like
perfect great and she'll go to cat camp
and learn how to act like a cat which is
a thing that all the actors had to do
i mean i have a guess as to how it
happened i have a guess is it just they
told her it would win oscars and she did
it
oh i was gonna say it it rhymes with
dump truck full of money well that's the
funniest thing is this the movie lost
hundreds of millions of dollars when it
hit the box office well sure i'm sure
i'm sure that dame dench made out like a
bandit but like
uh
i like to imagine that
they got these two like
critically lauded
octogenarians on the phone at the same
time and said listen guys
we are living in an exciting time this
is the advent of digital fur technology
and we want to get you guys in on the
ground yeah we want you guys to play
cats that that don't walk on all fours
but also do walk on all fours but also
walk on their hind legs but also don't
walk on their hind legs and
right
the whole thing i completely agree like
i saw it like not long after it came
yeah and uh
it feels very much like falling asleep
under too many blankets it it feels
it is a disconcerting i felt frightened
for a lot of it like i just felt scared
and disturbed and
i don't i know it's going to be like a
big midnight screening movie
eventually one day i never want to see
this movie ever again it hurt me on a
personal level just because it was so
unsettling and bad it hurt my feelings
it's it's it's so played out to say like
that that movie felt like it was a bad
trip or whatever but it really does
because like none of the rules are
consistent or apply from like shot to
shot and like you said like people
the sizes of everything change like it
it does it it does feel and they very
much and there is no plot of cats but
they kind of try to add a plot while
also not trying to add a plot and so it
makes the whole movie
that much more confusing and idris elba
can do magic but then that also doesn't
matter and
[Laughter]
there are a lot of very good video
essays about their out there on youtube
about cats go find them i'm not the
expert on this but
it's a terrible terrible movie with one
of the most stacked casts in recent
memory it's uh yeah it's up there yeah
it's the movie 43 of this decade
speaking of which
while you were talking i just pulled
that one up because i remember that when
we were initially going to have this
conversation this was a movie i was
going to bring up it's not on our list
on looper.com should be um
it probably should be
just i'll just remind you of some of the
people in movie 43
academy award winner emma stone
i'm gonna stop saying academy award
winner because i don't know who else
please don't no keep it going just
saying about everybody academy award
winner richard gere
academy award watcher leah schreiber
easy tiger
i'll stop doing that because it's a bad
joke also star of mixed nuts you're
talking about
dennis quaid greg kinnear
uh
seth macfarlane that's not a big
surprise um
hugh jackman and i was gonna say academy
award winner kate winslet yeah she's an
oscar winner wolverine yeah hugh jackman
plays a man
with an appendage a growth if you will
under his chin i don't know if we can
show the clip right here let's say this
we're either showing the clip or we're
showing a censored version of the clip
right now
uh so that'll be fun for the editors to
figure out maybe an artistic interpreter
use your imagination
photoshop later
movie movie 43 to the to the best of my
knowledge it's basically
a an anthology comedy movie where
there's just a bunch of different comedy
sketches again comedy sketches
uh thrown together starring like
huge a-listers yeah and then you're
right to use air quotes by the way
because i think the supreme court ruled
that legally you cannot call movie 43 a
comedy i believe that was a recent
decision handed down by the court i
think there was a
there's like some story behind this
movie where people were like tricked
into being in it i don't know i don't
know that's the only explanation that
makes any sense right
yeah there's a lot of people who are in
this movie who shouldn't be in a movie
like yeah anyway um i jumped in ahead of
saying ahead of my turn yeah i don't
know i need to find out like tom in the
meantime while i look this up can you
tell us about the worst movie starring
a great actor that you'd like to talk
about
positively yeah uh so mine is kind of a
it's a throwback to
uh uh
1978 you know in in the
months and years following star wars
uh explosion onto the pop culture scene
there were
so many uh attempts to cash in on on
what they had created on what george
lucas had created
but none of them
as far as i could tell was as blatant
or had as much david hasselhoff as a
movie called star crash
which came out
something like 10 months after uh star
wars did they started filming not long
after the first star wars movie came out
uh the director to his dying breath as
far as i know just kept saying that no
we were not trying to cash in on star
wars it's just
a complete coincidence that the entire
plot feels like you took every plot
piece from star wars and stuck it in a
boggle cube and just shook it until
everything fell into place
it's uh
it's terrible if you if you haven't seen
it i mean by all means give it a shot it
uh
it it does feel like the fever dream of
somebody that
just watched star wars for the first
time but the best part of it is that
you've got uh christopher plummer
christopher plummer plays the emperor of
the galaxy who shows up to give
shakespearean gravity to some of the
worst monologues oh man cinematic
history and
he had a great sense of humor about it
like any time that he talked about it he
was like they sent me to rome and that
was worth like i would have shot a porn
if they sent me to rome to do it but and
uh which is the the guy seemed like a
real treat oh yeah
but it's it's hard not to imagine that
this this wasn't the result of like
this generation of
aging
highly acclaimed actors who would get to
get like you know peter o'toole and then
christopher plummer and michael they
would all get together and drink scotch
and kind of get punchy and at some point
alec guinness said look i know that
everything about this script that you're
getting handed looks like trash
but this will keep paying your rent for
the rest of your life if you do it i
just did this thing called star wars it
doesn't make a lick of sense
but i will be okay forever because
right and they gave me
laser beams to play with yeah
[Laughter]
the whole time that uh he's on screen
like it's it's astonishingly clear that
they had him for like a day
and that they got all of his stuff in
one day they shot it from two different
angles and then
a hologram of his character would show
up and uh
he'd say whatever needed to be said at
least he wasn't he wasn't tricked into
it because
like
spitballing off the movie 43 thing i'm
sure you guys have heard the that bill
murray's explanation for being in
garfield is it's directed by somebody
whose last name is cohen and he thought
it was a cohen brother
he thought it was one of them he thought
it was joel and or ethan and i'm like
yeah buddy
i don't think that's true the worst part
is that he uh appeared on the scene
for tale of two kitties yeah
i think by that point the trick the
trick was on everyone else correct
but um what you were saying tom it
reminds me of um master of the universe
starring
frank langella as
skeletor
yeah like the difference there is that
like he had to like sit through
prosthetics and get his face turned into
a skull and deliver these lines like
he's a he's a literal cartoon character
um
so yeah that's that's one that should be
on our list too um and this list that
we're talking about is up on looper.com
and it's got a number of movies here
i'll just mention a couple leonardo
dicaprio and critters three from 1991.
uh clearly he was a small a small boy at
this point uh denzel washington in heart
condition uh co-starring bob hoskins as
i think either
i think bob hoskins is alive and denzel
washington is a ghost oh
sorcia ronan and the host now you said
nina you'd seen the host alone and i
remember very little which should tell
you a lot but it's i know it's it was
it's based on a book written by twilight
author stephanie meyer so i think they
thought it would spawn a very large
similar to twilight franchise which
i think you know we're not all still
living through host mania so i think
it's clear that didn't
that didn't pan out no one's uh no one
here is a host
yeah
um
we've got aloha starring emma stone as a
character of asians for which she
apologized later yeah emma stone is a
white lady and that that dovetails
nicely with one of the ones i wanted to
add to the conversation which was
scarlett johansson and ghost in the show
um a movie i saw in theaters uh it's
real bad real real bad
not a good movie
we've also got on this list a movie i
did see in theaters one of the only ones
i think i saw
charlize theron an aeon flux back in
2005. you saw aeon flux and these aon
flux in theaters now did you lose it
here was it a bit
if it was a bit i understand i love a
good bit
when i was uh in high school probably
there was a thing on television called
liquid liquid television on mtv
and it was just weird animated stuff on
late at night for
strange people like me
uh and people who use drugs i was not
one of them um
and flux is basically this this weird
dystopian sci-fi
thing
that had like spies and espionage and
action and
people dying and strange strange strange
stuff it went from these five minute
shorts to a half hour
tv show it was all weird it was cool i
won't say the animation style was like
wild right
very cool stuff i mean again i was an
adolescent and the way that they are
drawing the people in this show was
highly suggestive so i will fully admit
to that being part of the appeal
but then i'm in i'm in college or just
after college this big budget movie of
aeon flux comes out and i'm like i know
this
intellectual property i will go see this
movie i remember liking it i'll see the
movie why not it's one of the only
movies i fell asleep in i've no i you
rarely fall asleep at the movies i fell
asleep for probably
one third of this movie like the middle
chunk and i woke up and i was like i
don't know what's going on tom have you
ever fallen asleep during a movie
in theaters uh movies
at the movies almost definitely yeah
yeah uh you know what the second alice
in wonderland movie uh with johnny depp
yeah fell asleep during the first act
and i woke up and wonderland had turned
into a scab
that sounds unsettling
yeah unless i never woke up there's a
chance that you're still in that movie
you're still in the movies you're gonna
wake up soon but that sucks so much more
like if it's a franchise that you
actually care about or that you have
good memories associated with and then
it's so cool
enjoyed once right never mind
i enjoyed it i had fond memories of it
and i was you know keen to see what they
would do well and charlize theron is a
great actress so if she's in something
you know
and this is the movie
another another great uh thing here is
that this is a movie that she was
horribly injured on and had to like
do like years of rehab just for this oh
man
is that how she lost her arm from mad
max yeah yeah she was almost it says
here in the article she was almost
paralyzed during i remember that yeah
can you imagine like almost paralyzing
yourself for a on flush
those those are some of the ones in here
um
another few that i wanted to add to the
conversation
um we've got tom hanks in the circle on
the list now nina you said you read the
book i did it's um
it's not particularly good and i've
heard that the movie is somehow worse um
it's it's kind of a clumsy like big tech
is bad story that
has a it has very obvious brought to you
by sony yeah exactly yeah it being a
movie is pretty
disingenuous
yeah express guy
yeah yeah and the tom hanks villain
casting just never clicked which i think
he later kind of admitted um i believe
that's in the the piece on looper but
yeah it just
the the uh reveals are super telegraphed
way too obviously and it's just the book
is not great and i think um
yeah i mean
i don't see tom hanks playing that
character at all and so i just feel like
the guy who played
mr ross right not a confusion america's
dad right he's not a convincing uh evil
tech
billionaire who's get colin hanks for
that right yeah
my mom hates that guy really
irrationally
yeah i like college i don't have a
problem with him my mother wants him to
like leave the earth
he was great in the good guys a show
that was canceled
too soon um but on the subject of tom
hanks i wrote here as part of my list uh
the terminal which i think was i want to
say was that a steven spielberg movie or
ron howard one of those it's a big
director i don't remember which one it
is is is it also spielberg after catch
me if you can is that he did both
oh he did both
we did both that's upsetting yeah
i don't like that but so the terminal
that movie is the dude's stuck in an
airport yeah
i was really a no i was so mad at that
movie i threw a can at the tv and
accidentally turn it off
and my friend was really into it was
sitting right in front of the tv and i
liked her like turned it off right
before the very end it was nice
it was nice
are you kidding me
i would not be upset about that i would
be thrilled with the fact that i have a
friend who has such good any ability to
turn off yeah that's amazing i think it
was my tv too i would just be impressed
i was ready to do it
my friend
that's another and the last one i wanted
to add was jupiter ascending great cavs
oh terrific choice channing tatum mila
kunis sean bean
eddie redmon academy award winner eddie
redmon eddie redmayne
this is how he does it
first he talks like this
and then he yells
and that's kind of all he does back and
forth hopefully the video team will be
able to adjust my
volume for that but he just it goes from
where i don't see any reason to
back and forth the whole time and
nothing in the movie makes any sense
it's terrible what's that really weird
thing that happens like does somebody
like ride a dog through space or someone
is a dog there's something everything's
weird yeah channing tatum is
that's right he used to have wings
that's okay i knew there was something
about a flying dog see i i was not far
off now he just still has like he has
like hover boots and he flies around
yeah and he's a dog alien
he shoots his gun and i could have sworn
i saw this movie in theaters too i could
have sworn when he shot his laser gun
there was like the sound of barking
underneath the laser beam
zach might not be wrong
that's funny yeah movie's really not a
good movie it's a bummer of a movie
funny
he's a really good actor like
yeah i don't know there's i don't have a
wrap-up for this
these movies are bad
nina tom
did you ever fall asleep in a theater
yes
and it was uh what was your staring
there will be blood but i only missed
one subplot
don't put this on the video
i was no this is the closing 10 pm
screening it was really late
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe we love you
[Music]